rachel is with us in Indiana hey Rachel
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show thank
you how are you
better than I deserve what's up so I was
hoping to get your advice on something
so I took financial piece about a year
ago and I tried to get my husband oh but
you know he wouldn't go so he doesn't
really understand where I'm coming from
when I'm trying to take the appropriate
steps to you know complete all the baby
steps of cool and he keeps yeah he keeps
trying to like take out car loans and
like boat loans and buy car I mean like
a truck to pull the boat you know and
I'm like we're on completely different
pages and we do have student loans so
I'm just trying to like take it for a
steps but I don't really know what
approach to take like you know it's like
for like getting arguments about it you
know they mean how old are you guys I
hate and he is 29 how long you been
married
going on ten years ago well this is why
we generally recommend that you not go
to a Financial Peace University unless
your spouse will go with you because it
causes more problems more problems not
less because what's happened is you've
gotten some very definite financial
information and goals and they
constantly conflict with his his
impulsive and childish spending right
correct yeah so you're starting to feel
like the mommy yeah that's what I'm
trying to avoid and the little boys
whining because he can't buy a toy you
are correct this mommy won't go along
with it yeah and that's that's a very
dangerous place for y'all's relationship
to get into are you guys in a good
church um I am I'm just trying to get
him to go is a work in progress yeah so
so there's a whole lot of stuff you do
he doesn't do and a whole lot of stuff
he does you don't do
um yeah it's more so like I'm doing it
and he doesn't do it so many things um
unless something jolts him I ha I'm
afraid as an old guy who's watched this
happen a lot that you guys are not gonna
make it because you're gonna reach the
point that you're disgusted living with
a little boy you're not yet you still
kind of think it's cute and you're still
romantically in love and that's
wonderful and I'm glad you are but
you're going to reach the point of
frustration that you're tired of raising
him if something doesn't happen this is
a real dangerous place for you I'm not
trying to be mean to him
and I'm not trying to just be smart at
like or something like that I I suspect
if we've if the patterns continue that
if you were to go to a marriage
counselor he would not go yeah because
he doesn't think there's any problems
but I would suggest that a marriage
counselor would help you under help you
help him understand that there's
problems so you need you need to contact
your pastor and ask them for a good
Christian marriage counselor to meet
with hopefully your husband will go with
you but there's a lot of things going on
in your life that are not trending the
right way let me tell you what I'm
talking about now back up 3 steps okay
because I just threw some cold water on
you and I don't want to I don't want to
leave you there but we know
statistically that the research tells us
that couples before they get married if
they go to pre-marriage counseling if
they can agree on four things they have
a high probability of marital success
every one of those four that drop out
tell us that there's a high probability
of lack of marital success meaning
divorce okay number one is fights over
money it's the number one cause of
divorce in North America today
number two is religion and so far euro
four to number three is raising the kids
and whether to have kids and how many to
have do you have kids
I do not okay there you all want to have
kids
um maybe we're not quite sure on that
yet who wants to who does not
well we both do we're just I actually
just recently applied for dental school
so if I get in then that's another four
years of schooling and then I just I
don't want to have kids
also all right and the last one is
in-laws dealing with them dealing with
crazy and your family and there's crazy
and every family so um you know if you
can get on the same page dealing with
in-laws kids money and religion those
four things are high indicators that
you're going to have a high quality
sustainable marriage that's what the
data tells us from all the research and
you guys have to at least two of those
missing and that's what's scaring me for
you if you were my son-in-law and
daughter I would take you all out to
dinner and very calmly tell you all
these things in an effort to scare you
to death so you go do something about
this before it blows up in your face
yeah so go see a marriage counselor
kiddo and beg him to go with you because
if you do not get to the bottom of this
and you all do not get some common
ground on this and some compromise on
these issues you're not gonna make it in
ten years it'd be just a minor I mean
one less one of you just dysfunctional
and crazy and codependent and then you
can stay together but that's not really
staying together that's someone's spirit
left their body and left their body in
the marriage but I'm talking about a
healthy marriage it's not going to be
two quality people functioning together
you're not gonna be there in ten years
because you're not heading there right
now and it's not going to do with
financial peace it's not going to Dave
Ramsey you're not in agreement on some
of the life's biggest issues what money
flows to tells us what you think is
important and religion you know what we
think about God what do we think about
eternity these are these are important
topics for the human being to be in
agreement on when you're married I hope
that helps you I think you can make it I
know you can turn it around
or sharon married a guy just like that
so she we got around it but uh it took a
lot of bonking on my head I'll tell you
that